President Trump and the first lady are
back at the White House this morning
after a surprise visit to US troops in
Iraq the president slipped out of
Washington around midnight on Christmas
and he spent about three hours on the
ground yesterday at an airbase just west
of Baghdad the president had been
criticized for waiting nearly two years
to visit US military units in a combat
zone David Martin is at the Pentagon for
us David good morning good morning it's
been a head-spinning week in which the
president in order to pull out from
Syria and fired his Secretary of Defense
after he had first resigned in protest
the Pentagon is sputtering with anger
but for the troops in the field the
commander-in-chief is still a rock star
dressed for the part the president took
credit for what he called the near
elimination of Isis even though fighting
is still going on in Syria when I became
president there were a very dominant
group they were very dominant today
they're not so dominant anymore CBS News
chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett was there
[Music]
America shouldn't be doing the fighting
for every nation on earth if they want
us to do the fighting they also have to
pay a price and sometimes that's also a
monetary price so we're not the suckers
of the world we're no longer the suckers
folks he insisted the decision to pull
out of Syria was not as sudden as it
seemed that he had told the military to
get out a year and a half ago but kept
giving in to their requests to stay
another six months and he answered the
one question most Iraqis and all the
troops have will the u.s. pull out of
Iraq as well no plans at all fifteen
years after American tanks rolled into
Baghdad Air Force One had to take
extraordinary security precautions to
fly into the country anywhere to have a
concern I had a concern security was so
tight the White House gave the Iraqi
Prime Minister just two hours notice for
a meeting with the president the Prime
Minister couldn't make it so they
settled for a phone call
president Trump left without meeting any
Iraqi officials and now members of the
Parliament are calling for a vote to
expel American troops Dana David thank
you